our silver medal winner is from a school
that over the years has been no stranger
to our awards made at Columbia
University by Cassandra Lazare and Kelly
asmath their film the weight follows
four seriously ill teenagers living with
futures unknown as they await Oregon
transplants that may or may not happen
this is a powerful film I am very
pleased to present the silver medal
award in documentary filmmaking -
Cassandra Lazar and Kelly
asmath thank you so much this whole week
has been unbelievable the Board of
Governors and the Academy Committee
you've been so gracious and sharing your
time and experience with us and it's
unbelievable to us that you've even
watched our film so we'd also like to
thank our advisor Lenny for being with
us every step of the way
and above all we'd like to thank Tricia
nyesha Kristen and Ryan and their
families for opening up their lives to
us and sharing their lives with us we'd
also like to thank our families and
friends for putting up with us
throughout this whole process and for
their unconditional support on that note
I'd like to recognize my parents who are
here today thank you for all your love
and support over the years you've always
encouraged me and everything I wanted to
do and I'm so thankful also thankful to
my friends who are here we're very
pleased to announce that as of last
month all four of the young people who
were featured in the film has power
receive the transplants I think that
they need it and thank God it were we're
celebrating with them and we wish them
continued health and success and all
they do we hope that we hope that this
film will continue to touch and
encourage and inform many many more
people thank you so much
you